this is the war zone kings one-minute
war zone rated 88 players
1820 average rating time handicapped
here we go turn it on let's do it double
those points double or nothing
okay it's the same old baloney but what
can you do you're trying to win quick
here in the war zones pawn push pawn
push pawn takes pawn takes okay Queen
check I don't know about that you're
gonna grab that pawn and hang onto it
and get that Queen Bishop takes pawn be
very scared okay I want to target this
guy pins pins everywhere let's take this
Queen here I want to get that pun with
my rook okay now we're not having that
are we okay let's let's get that up I
was ready to take that pawn this is uh I
would not be good I think there might
have been a rucksack on that on Knight
so that's why I went there
f7 is guarded by my nighttime on c3 I
could have taken that and I should have
taken that get out of there you cannot
deal with that Queen right here oh that
is just a drop Queen resign they don't
have a time edge they're not resigning
there are non resigner come over here
over here just some Primo's fifteen
seconds I get this real quick a mate - I
just want to kill that pawn I sneak in
here that's not happening let's just
play here what bad can happen if you're
here just take that Knight look at how I
just ran away scared anything anything
anything anything oh that's not mean is
it it's close to it Primo's three and a
bunch of two's
very early on Jonathan cm fishings
fishing pole okay we have the Fort Knox
Fort Knox defense back to tournament why
am I not up there I am up there I'm just
not highlighted six quick resigner clay
Clayton trip here we go
you are seeing it again does it get old
I'm sure it does but this is what you
have to do I'm still gonna try for it
you know you want a castle and I want to
get my Queen Bishop on this diagonal
because sometimes it's gonna be g3 that
white will do to defend the mate threat
on h2 and when g3 is played f3 and h3 is
weakened why is my opponent not moving
or they think tank time 43 seconds each
what's happening and what's up with this
clock look at this clock take it out of
there Clark
get out of there clock over here okay
they got rid of my Nightcrawler right
there oh the bishop is dead uh-oh I just
want to give a queen check right here
I'm gonna keep the Queen's on and me
King King f1 where's the King gonna go
let's go Knight do something good here
I'm gonna Bishop out right here and then
get to f4 with a knight move and then
I'm on the Queen uh-oh
this is brutal I think by force the
queen is lost I think I don't know the
King has to move or something
tough situation no time just do anything
no time they're down on time back to
tournament twelve twelve twelve and then
six okay I think there's a better chance
of getting paired up with the cap in the
this tournament because there are fewer
players maybe I should have considered
what what should I have considered
everybody stopping this night the night
stuff to g5 it's being sniffed out
everybody is well aware of the tricks
stop that night from doing stuff I'm
gonna play here and go after my
light-square bishop maybe whoa
light-square weaknesses let's pounce on
the nut the the light-square weaknesses
how do you do that reposition maneuver
get your knight juicy squares right here
h5 was beautiful let's go here right now
my knight wants to be right here I
should probably deca cream of that light
squares pawn push maybe I'm on the
bishop Oh they've been a deadly deadly
deadly fork incoming right here
oh the rook is cooked that is officially
one cook truck right there and I'm gonna
be up a full ruck now because of that
are they gonna resign are they gonna
play on five or 15 seconds left I'm on
the Queen anything I just don't want any
seconds even if it's a bad move even if
this is bad I just want to do it
anything don't let my clock tick
precious seconds and they'd hear
anything back to tournament twenty my
name isn't being highlighted 20 I'm in
second right there Jonathan cm c5
again back to turn oh man what is going
on here Edie BOGO let's go with the
Bishop c4 and this clock is dead by the
way that I'm that's in my corner here on
the right hand side it's the most
ridiculous clock right here oh man this
night needs to be pinned otherwise night
d4 is a problem
get out of there night before you punish
me oh let's punish the rook that's what
happens I totally relate to that the
mouse slippers get the best of everybody
if the bishop went back I had g4 f5
let's play here my bishop wants to
recapture that pun and I'm okay with
double puns up material that's okay
bishop you need to get out of there
because I need to castle the Knights
gonna be killing me rook takes Bishop is
available in 95 the bishop is ready to
be dead a lot of good things that pond
could be taken this night can be taken
I'm gonna go after that guy while they
get my guy oh oh oh oh where is the
sneaky stuff right here smash this open
may coming up right around the corner
mate in one
back to tournament 42 42 30 22 let's go
hear crash the 3p c5 and c6 okay a six
Queen c7 knight c6 d5 on the night you
see it fishing fishing fishing they're
not going they're not gonna go in that
direction the Queen move told me that
they're gonna go Queen side or are they
my queen wants to stay here okay they're
going there I want to get at this point
okay I got a guard this Knight position
I hear they don't have g4 what's going
on with this there's no mate on this on
these squares over here R is there I
have these covered stay here I think
it's safe let's play here I need to get
castled the bishop might kick me around
a little bit okay wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait a second wait a second
Queen right here would have been a nice
in-between move be careful captured the
Queen I'm up a pond and I want my bishop
to be right there but uh okay get out of
there I have to deal with this bishop in
this way get out I'm not even
threatening to take it because if rook
takes there there might be a queen check
or something coming up no Queens on the
board so what do you do you guard the
you guard the seventh rank here and you
get your king up King wants to play over
here and this pawn wants to be up what's
the clock count
I just dropped upon what's the pond
count that's the better one okay let's
play here guard this a pond before it's
too late King position this guy's flying
he's a flier this King is gonna be
kicked away King f3 I'm in check you
can't move your palm like that if you're
in check let's go over here let's go
with b4 b4 is the plan coming up b4 and
it stopped let's come back over here
before I still want to play or no I
don't I want to change my attention to
this c3 pawn get over here I'm on the
rook are they gonna go on the defensive
soon they're gonna go on the defensive
they're on the defensive and my rook
wants to get to see for next and I do
that by playing a4 so I make the sea
Foursquare available here we go lateral
movement next pawn push or actually baby
step it like this this is a passed pawn
coming up running out of squares in a
fork deadly fork Pass pawn over here I
should just grab that pawn over here
okay here I'm just going to take on that
Square a bunch of times
clock situation over here don't you dare
give a check it's okay I have this as a
past pun don't be stalemate whatever you
do there down on time back to term in 56
42:56 42 36 35 happy efore let's try
this the alp ins this clock is stupid
off to show to you if I get a second
just dropped upon why did I drop upon
man it's not a happy not a happy day
here
let's guard this can I actually still do
out right here do I have something let's
try it let's try it
oh it's been shut down black says no I
will have none of your fishing pole
antics Bishop check is available or is
it the Queen is coming out and thank
take spawn
we're not or not where's my king gonna
go let's come over here is it safe over
here
better be let's take care okay okay okay
okay
oh no no no no no no no no no no no no
no bishop right here and then queen 2f1
would have been a killer I think I want
a weasel around is there any weaseling
available there might be there might be
there might be dark square weaknesses oh
I need to defend though I just want the
Queen's off please just let the Queen's
come off please yes yes just let the
Queen's come off hopefully this is gonna
be okay I'm gonna walk into this but
this is okay I think okay just in time I
don't have any time
what am i time go I have to kick it into
a high gear I don't have this
what's the clock situation I don't have
it there's no time can I get this make
and I get it can I get it can I get it
they're gonna take my rook they're
definitely gonna take my rook give a
check I don't have this can I get a mate
you know you want a queen you know you
want a queen you know you want to clean
I gotta go for a perpetual it's a
drought to perpetual I'll take the
perpetual I was a dead man if I didn't
get the perpetual 72 oh where did my
time go to what that game man where did
my time go what was that guy's rating
wow I need to make up a ton of ground
right now uh-oh uh-oh
right here right here right here
deflection right here deflection it's a
good move the Queen moves I take the
knight and then they take on each two
this is resign time no no no no
take care and then each two deflection
back to tournament that was a quick kill
90 70 to 50 44 let's go here let's go
this this clock is being of no help to
me at oh no help to me it's saying one
hour and negative 1 hour 49 minutes 44
seconds I have to check the time I do
not know how much time is left
oh man oh you know what happened with
that game I dropped upon that's what
happened that's why life was so
difficult and this guy is ready to kill
me because of the silly stuff that I've
been doing so far in this game and I
want to get a majority going these guys
need to go I'm just gonna do this even
if it is wrong I think it's the right
thing to do so I could always have an e6
move available
let's try this Bishop takes okay let's
try this or not you're gonna lose stuff
if you do that okay and now get the
Queen over here Bishop takes pawn just
take my bishop you know you want to take
that darn it
take this rook you know you want to take
that rook it's probably okay to do that
or it is it or it is or it is it I have
Queen takes pawn this is working out
sneaky tricks I didn't even calculate
that just happened to work out you know
you want to move Queen so I could play
here that's me
that's a slick maid I'll take the slick
mates and I'm up there no I'm not up
there 110 he's not gaming right in right
there anti network oh no this can't be
good I can't be good if you're playing
is the anti network man anti network you
can't win against the anti network okay
let's go wow I should have had a queen
check mmm let's go with this okay let's
come back here pawn push pawn push
eventually let's try that sneaky castle
and then stop them from castling what
are they doing what do we have here I'm
gonna grab that night no I want my
Bishop here and then my knight here with
the check uh-oh uh-oh
stuff is falling now no I didn't want to
take that I wanted to give check okay
let's try this sneaky stuff I'm on the
Queen where's the main it's right around
the corner
It's Made if it they take the bishop
they're gonna time burner it time burner
this is the anti network
okay where's the mate looking for the
mates did I miss a mate I was ready to
play Queen here let's not do that
they're just gonna burn the clock
they're not gonna fall for a mate in one
take that night you know you want to
take them mate in one threat double
checkmate be very scared be very scared
ten seconds they're gonna milk every
tenth of a second from this one milk and
the clock double check me yes 110 110 14
minutes left look at this clock stupid
why play checkers okay ah let's try this
I could turn into a French very easily
okay let me try this oh wait a second
I'm gonna try this light-square
weaknesses uh-oh get that light squared
bishop and look at the g6 square very
closely my knight wants to be where to
throw that check in there and get more
development in I don't want to go for a
queen trade here let's come you did your
job Queen now get back over here there's
more exciting things
okay let's scar that pond it's an
important pond open this up over here
I'll pet this and then I have a pond
push right in the center open this up
right here grab this pond I'm on this
night Forks checks grab this pond
discovered checks available rook checks
on d7 rook checks the night is dead
like a premium of this are they gonna
resign this is main just move King just
move back to termit they resigned that
was a quick one 130 131 14 there's 13
minutes I think left 13 minutes left and
Oh a quick resigner 140 another quick
resigner 12 and change 13 games in let's
go efore alla pins again
and night out and my bishop wants to be
on d3 and I want any out of my EEP on
this time you know you want a castle
just castle it's gonna be okay it's
still gonna be okay just castle it's
still gonna be okay castle come on you
know you want a castle now they're
clearly gonna sniff that one out I'm on
the knight though this pond could fall
let's guard this guy there was maybe a
knight move there let's stop pawn push
is probably good I'm gonna take care
even if it's wrong and I open this up
maybe pawn push and Bishop here bishop
g6 where's the main the knight has to
block now otherwise it's me if the King
moves it's me that was a quick main back
to tournament 160 150 14 12 games and
160 150 114 anti Network again ah what
can you do what can you do the anti
network all right let's go with some
stuff in the center it's tough to get
this working over here let's get this
out here and castle so we're not gonna
have any quick kills can i exploit this
pin though somehow 53 seconds so it's in
a pin I'm looking to pile up on it I
don't want to lose my bishop if I did
that I'd lose my bishop I have this move
available maybe I should've done it
okay now I'm on this pawn and let's play
here I want to take that rook and then
play there okay this is working I got a
fork out of it and what next it's a free
rook and I want to save my knight or at
least make white work a little bit
harder to get back at it and that's not
gonna be well he's dead I got to do this
or do this pawn push or something real
soon if it's attacked right away I
really don't have anything maybe Bishop
here pawn push ideas
I like this pawn push idea first 20
seconds left for white clock burner
was this account created just to be an
anti and non mover what can you do what
can you do anything anything pre move it
pre move it
Clark burner o'clock burn now they have
to check the server Oh No
checking the server nine these are
precious seconds come on four three two
one
goose egg back to Turman one 91-89
minutes and change let's go let's go
efore you could do it you could do it
you could do it
don't you dare drop that pawn again no
more dropping of the e pawns Bishop g4
there's gonna be a pin or is there I
gotta take like this let me pin that
night and I'm gonna take the knight and
then I could take like this on that
twice keep this in a pin and I think I
have well let's do that anyhow and kick
that night around a little bit it can't
be too comfortable with being kicked
around pawn push again oh oh oh man now
there's gonna be night there or is there
now there isn't I have Bishop there
available this can't be right
double-check me if you take it's a
double checkmate
uh move Knight this is okay I'm gonna
clean around the night this is check
stop castling queenside castle our rook
to d1 one of the two where does the
Queen gonna go she's running short on
squares take care and then do this I'm
on the Queen I'm on the knight again and
let's do this is this working I get that
I get the Queen Queen side cast our King
side Castle is this working
no I can't do that back to basics
you can't castle through check shame on
you you know you can't do that
come on get out of there King looking
for deflections where the deflections
there
okay let's pin that pin the rook cross
pins everywhere
check get out of that nonsense no time
no time no time no time back to time
with 200 237 and change to 3200 double
those points
man I got a win like really really quick
really really quick
where are the quick ones okay sneak that
in sneak that in there's queenside
castle coming up I'm gonna Castle
kingside a queen site where are you
gonna go okay that stops that get out of
there night and I think well let's guard
here although Bishop pin is probably a
good idea there I just dropped a pond
but I have a central push at the end of
it well not right away in fact I
shouldn't do it right away because my
queen is hanging let's do this first and
then upon pushing him on the clean I'm
on the Queen it might be missed pawn
push here it is missed the queen is dead
come on come on resign are they gonna
resign now they're playing on forks
domino effect one piece Falls the others
fall mates I should just take in the
bishop first well I just dropped my
queen I just dropped my queen it was a
free queen Bishop takes Queen oh man
devastating it's devastating all the
blunders look at the mouth free rooks
and everything uh-oh I'm on h2h - it
doesn't lead to me let's do this cuz the
knight could block but maybe this is
working check it stake here
and Bishop goes somewhere else I have a
check here these games are going too
slow too slow anything anything anything
anything where's the main where is the
main I mean one next no matter what
where'd you go where'd you go where'd
you go right here like determined to
2268
oh man how do you catch 268 five minutes
and change link 3 2 1 ok have to go for
this I gotta go for a gambit style stuff
ok well where's that Bishop gonna go ok
well can I get this where is uh what's
the plan here I got defense for that
night let's go and I'm going to actually
post up in the center and get a center
built push that bishop away soon get out
of there
look right here and I think I want to do
just a pawn push or a knight Knight move
right there
it looks pretty appealing soon actually
right here take that pawn and then do
this then rook right here and then pawn
push let's do this I'm looking for
another pawn push that knight is pinned
let's just do this it's not working
let's try this I'm giving up ok this
file is open opening up now I'm on the
Queen I'm on the night and I'm on the
brook ok
Wow mates where are the mates
is this working I got a rook check and
then a queen check for me I think it's
working out rook check on d8 this is
matin one two back to tournament two
4288 holy smokes 288 242 19 204 I think
I would need to end up being paired up
with them of course being able to beat
them and well I wouldn't I would need to
beat him Bishop back he gets trapped
okay so I had to run away I had Queen
takes pawn I'm gonna try it or not I'm
too afraid
hmm get out of there night and let's get
more development in I should try age six
g5 I would need a lot I need a lot to
have happen in order to get that in
that's a free pun lanes kicked away and
okay I could set it up now let me
queenside castle first
what is the clock situation okay that
pond is gonna be hit that Bishop is free
at this point you give a check here
Bishop d6 the Queen could take here that
should be alright and I want to get my
other rook right here or maybe actually
night right here take the night mate and
two or three mmm I really don't want to
have to do that oh well the Queen's
gonna come back there or is she want to
take the knight and then get it h2 is it
it's not made though or is it it might
be made it's me
coming up no matter what Queen here
that's me back to tournament 260 308 oh
that's too difficult to overcome
okay this guy has is he just resigning
to people I need quick wins I gotta do
reckless stuff I gotta do reckless stuff
I have to go for his scholars maids and
all that fun stuff man
is it gonna work it's not gonna work is
it that's too much I'll just take that
pond I guess keep my queen around can I
trap that Queen Castle kingside watch
out from a non situ Bishop takes pawn if
the knight moves pawn push in the center
ok let's come back I want to kill that
night play here very soon I'm gonna take
the pawn in the center I think that's
good
very good very good move Knight right
there he needs to go and where is the
main looking for the mates and it's not
there just yet right here clock
situation this guy is doing quite well
for this rating they have ok queen h5
with check let's defend that pawn I read
it come over here Queen takes h6 c2 is
gonna come under fire and sure enough
that's what we're having right here
let's defend this I also have Queen
takes h6 maybe get my pawn involved
Queen takes f6 might be good ok they're
coming over to the other side of the
board now and I'm in trouble I got a run
for the hills and I'm not able to run
for the hills ok I got to do this I got
to give up my um I got to do this never
check another check where the time
burners oh there's problems here big
problems serious problems over in this
direction I don't want to go in the
other direction otherwise get made it at
the games drawn repetition 24 ticks
there was no catching him cap this game
isn't even gonna finish the pack leader
is here ok oh don't go don't go there
the knight would have killed me I'll
just grab that pawn wolf why am I not
moving
okay they got that I got that am I
getting the night at the end of it I did
not calculate that uh it's just not
finishing game over second a tournament
over second place confetti was way out
of first place on that one
that was a beastly score right there man
348 that's nearly a hundred Wow twenty
three twenty eighteen to my 348 two
sixty two thirty nine to twenty two
nineteen a bunch in the 200s oh man way
off games